I'm mad all the time might tell you just
you know angry angry angry pain in the
neck but in the morning I would get up
maybe 45 minutes earlier to do
meditation before I was able to face
that set recreate movies don't pay
attention industry do your own thing
thinking in the morning where to do this
then about two hours interpreter suit
we're doomed
we're never finishing this film we're
gonna be in movie hell for the rest of
our lives he's an American director
producer screenwriter and actor whose
career spans more than 50 years part of
the new Hollywood wave of filmmaking
he's considered one of the most
influential and greatest filmmakers of
all time with eight Best Director
nominations he's the most nominated
living director he's Martin Scorsese and
here is my take on his top ten rules for
success rule number seven is my personal
favorite and make sure to stick around
although to the end for some special
bonus clips also as you watch listen to
Martin in these clips if there's
something that he says that really
resonates with you added to the comments
below with quotation marks so we can
keep track I'm wondering when you're
trying to make a film and you come up
against obstacles and barriers what do
you attribute your strong dedication to
getting that film made um really I this
area usually hysteria and obsession and
anger I think mainly anger
I'm mad all the time Mike Patel you just
you know angry angry angry pain in the
neck that's why I use humor a lot
because it deflates myself I don't want
to take it seriously because I really do
you I would have been gone much longer
25 years ago but I wouldn't survive but
the anger is enormous but everything
about everything and so that also fuels
me to make a picture
I think but keeping the sense of humor
is the key thing the irony the irony
when you get there in the morning and
you get a note that one actors have the
ribs break down and you can't go on with
the film
it happened it happened yeah they don't
want to come out of the trailer right
here no black sweater what are you gonna
get a heart attack otherwise or you kill
someone you know it's not good without
meaning to be presumptuous what
sacrifices do you think you've made in
order to create the work to make the
films to make the career that you've
done what do you think in your life
you've sacrificed I think you know as a
little friend old priest told me said
you pay a price you know when you pay a
prices I just quite honestly you know a
personal life really and relationships
go by the board I mean it was as if the
Frank Capra quote it's like being like a
drug or something that you have to
continue and now as I say some people
call that drive some call it obsession
some call just being selfish and being
not a very nice person but the reality
is that I just had to continue that
process what do you do when you when you
change how the world thinks of cinema
what's next I mean do you keep making
the same kind of film or a few person
like Rosselini if you are you try
something experimental you push further
it's not just experimental for
experimental experiments Inc but you
push the boundaries further to talk to
me I talk to the group about why the
subjects and the difficulties in getting
films like what can you ever do anything
that's easy
I mean club but I guess any film is not
really easy I mean I would think but I
think you're driven by something that's
like an obsession I would think and
before you realize that you have your
eye for the eye piece and you say we're
crazy how the hell are we ever going to
do this this is madness but you keep
going you keep going and I never really
thought otherwise I actually thought
people wanted to see that kind of plan
and it the industry changed
I started making mean streets with 73 so
you know taxi driver
the Raging Bull in New York New York
particularly the Last Waltz and that
less walleston somewhat of a different
story but actually I actually had no I
really was surprised that they would be
resistance to like taxi driver for
example it was very difficult to get
made and certainly Last Temptation of
Christ I understood there would have
been some controversy but usually from
certain certain areas not necessarily
what happened at the time so we just go
ahead and then you know eventually
there's some studio people and in the
case of taxi driver was a combination of
DeNiro and myself you just start
Godfather two we mean streets when I de
mean streets of working hands would
print up the seat to show Francis
Coppola in San Francisco and he hired De
Niro from Easter for Godfather two based
on that that led to taxi driver and then
Raging Bull was a project of De Niro's
really I remember doing a film called
you go which is a film shot in three
dimensions and it took about an hour to
get there to the studio but in the
morning I would get up maybe 45 minutes
earlier to do meditation before I was
able to face that set with children
actors that can only work for like a
minute
a dog that wasn't listening Sacha Baron
Cohen was improvising everything and
everything in 3d that's an over schedule
and over budget so you know God there's
only the one thing you could do is calm
it down and get into it and deal with
the realities if there is something on
my mind if there is something I'm really
worried about in terms of a character
development or particularly a thematic
issue or just trying to get a shot done
literally isn't what we can't do that we
don't have a hallway it's got to be a
track down the hallway we have no hall
now what what is it about it's about his
face all right and so you just forget it
and you go into meditation that's it and
somehow something came out I said damn
it that's me I did my first short film
at the summer workshop in 63 that's
where I met Thelma Schoonmaker
yeah she was a history major I believe
at Columbia and Thelma Schoonmaker is
Marty's editor and this
is without overstating it one of the
truly great collaborations in motion
pictures so for somebody who has a
vision like Marty to get other people
because you've got to get other people
to do it with you who are on the same
frequency who understand what you're
looking for who share the vision and it
can make it happen
that's priceless yeah this really isn't
that that's the struggle to it yeah
because it is collaborative if I could
shoot it and if I could edit it myself
and if I could write it if I can act in
it fine but I can't write so you need
people who are like-minded in a way or
exploring certain areas that you want to
go to possibly at a certain point in
your life but with them and myself you
know we edit films it's like I would say
we're getting to be like like two older
people in a cottage making a three-piece
suit but you know sort of stitching it
by hand you know they banging on the
door the studio they want the picture
I'll be right with you just look you
gotta put cuffs on the pants you know
that's it but it's it's that sort of
thing and there's a lot of care that
goes into it and a lot of a lot of time
that's spent in the actual editing
really in the face make your own
industry recreate movies don't pay
attention to industry do your own thing
I mean put it this way um you want the
work to be seen but it doesn't have to
be at the Odeon you know no more that's
all different that's all gone to another
ancient world that type of film or not
even that type of film the communal
experience is always important you can
make a film on a camera the size of that
doorknob and still show it to 1600
people in an audience it's still a great
communal experience you know it doesn't
necessarily mean it has to cost over a
hundred million pounds have you ever
done a movie where everything pretty
much fell into place and there were no
monumental battles no anxiety no angst
no near nervous breakdowns which seems
to be actually kind of what your life is
about pretty much as Leah
has it ever been a movie where it just
started and what do we have 45 days
sheeting did it like not never never
I mean I'm shooting at 2:00 in the
morning last night and you know you find
yourself in the edge of the seat like
this frozen you know the actors are
moving a certain way what is it gonna
maybe I think I should be more to the
left what do you think Michael Ball
knows yeah move in more tears well I
have a problem left to right rafter
whenever I say left go left no right
that's it right and the guys are looking
at me Marty I don't know it definitely
but it's that kind of thing you can't
the minute you become also as you get
older to you sometimes it be with the
heat on the sudden this week was very
hard you do from time that time to get
that energy a midday you need like 15
minutes close your eyes just think but
you you have to keep you there's no such
thing too or if you love shooting well
for me shooting is is an extraordinarily
stressful situation because there's not
one moment to relax you know because you
need to push you need to first of all
not only get something wonderful from
the actors and then cinematographer and
everybody but you have to do it on a
schedule and you have to prove that
you're responsible you have a certain
responsibility 96 million dollars 100
million doc yeah responsibility to do
what you can with that money and you're
presented there you have to make the
deck today means you get to the end
you've done the setups and the pages
that's the way they judge it yes these
things and then you usually feel
sometimes well not shooting a schedule
for God text making a film but then you
realize well you know at a certain point
if we can sometimes you slip behind
we've been able like for example an
aviator that picture came in on schedule
90 days on schedule with all that stuff
with the airplanes everything I don't
know how we did it but there wasn't one
day that we didn't suffer kind of the
ups and downs of it thinking in the
morning where to do this then about two
hours inside which is it were doomed
finishing this film we're gonna be in
movie hell for the rest of our lives the
plains Howard use I don't know what's
going on where are we and then to I was
like hey yeah by the end of the day you
guys oh god we made it you know surprise
or you slipped over to the next day and
cut down another scene and somehow it
all came together yeah you know I'm
saying we look better by the time the
dust and settled we looked around it was
90 days we did it you know in gangs was
it was a different thing was it was a
much bigger epic I was like looking
around we're never day you know we just
never got there you know but that's the
last of that kind that can be done
what's the hallmark of a great script
how do you know you you want to choose
that one over the thousands of our
hundreds of others that you look at what
personal a personal I usually I don't
read other people's scripts and I
usually develop something or I have
something in mind and I work with a
friend usually in some cases big Pileggi
in other cases Jake oxen or hire Paul
Schrader for bringing out the dead but
when he went for example when taxi
driver was given to me to read by Brian
DePalma I hadn't done mean streets yet
and so but he said it you'd be great for
this and automatically I mean it had to
be an emotional connection to the
material into the characters the
obsessive mess of Travis Bickle the
sense of being the outsider and not
being the dispossessed that's how I you
know we felt that way I mean myself and
I could speak for DeNiro to a certain
extent because we didn't articulate it
that way I can't really say oh you know
we're outside say we were trying to get
in we're trying to stay in Hollywood
moving down this thing it was a painful
script so I mean usually you really they
a lot of most amorites words come from
ideas and books and he then developed
strips in the early years there were
some screenplays but as you progress on
you yeah Alice was a screenplay and then
enough but certainly taxi driver when
you got that I said this this one has to
be made and we just knew it and but
after that no after that the world
developed the way Mike where Mike said I
think yes yes I think so
New York stories for example life
lessons with Nick Nolte it was that
based on I'd always wanted to do
something of dusty HP because actually
the first process T I read was notes
from underground that was taxi driver
really so you know I say I feel like
that that's me
that's what it makes you really you
really identified with it you know who
was on here the other day the kid Jonah
Oh Jonah hell yeah and he was talking
about a scene where he's got to take a
punch from a thug mm-hmm and it was a
fake punch and he was going to pretend
to be hit and you you went over and said
to him we're really gonna hit you yes no
at that point I had to do it yeah he was
going to have my nerves and that was the
end of Oh Jonah could get you crazy
he's not going to stop laughing it's in
the film but he was knocked unconscious
I'm actually but he pretended that
innovative for a moment there I thought
he was now so maybe went too far yeah
maybe you went too far
are there are there other actors you
have hurt in your career Joe Pesci Joe
Pesci what what did you do to him I
didn't do it it was you know all the
fight scenes and all the craziness in
that film Raging Bull all the
physicality us the last two days of
shooting or something we did a scene
with the De Niro and Pesci in the boxing
ring over at the there was a gym on 14th
Street which is gone now
and they had protective gear on this is
one of the strangest things where you
see these action films I don't know how
people really don't get badly hurt
because with the protective gear there
were a couple of couple of punches
thrown and the last punch just as I yell
cut Bob just hit by accident really the
protective gear on the chest of Joe and
we heard this and I said Bob that was
great I said what was that that was a
broken rib
and it took and he really broke it
cracked his rib and it was just by
accident with gear on and that's in the
film - that sound is there and then we
had we had the opportunity to revisit it
again on casino mmm oh is the same same
the same red no yes how did this happen
well he was on the floor and it was a
big guy holding him down and every time
I'd say cut this big guy who was like
200 pounds would sir use Joe as a Hasek
or something you put it and Joe said
don't do it don't use me as a Hasek how
many times I gotta tell you
and sure enough crack a second rib
you're lucky you're still in business
yes
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I made this video
because Lenovo Chunin asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it down in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do
I'd also love to know which of Martin's
top ten rules had the biggest impact on
you and why
what made you reflect what really
touched your soul in some way leave in
the comments and I will join the
discussion also if any of his quotes
that have been posted below that you see
in quotation marks that you really
enjoyed make sure to give it a thumbs up
to show your appreciation
finally one think of a quick shadow to
need a sing Nita thank you so much for
buying two copies of my book it really
means a lot to me those you watching if
you want your chance at a shadow in the
future video make sure to grab a copy of
the book and also email in your receipt
so we can keep track thank you guys so
much for watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon
this was Schrader's passion in a way and
then somehow we picked up on it and was
DeNiro myself no felt as powerfully just
had attached to it as as Schrader did a
New York New York came out came came
from something that I wanted to an
explorer genre and I started a fool
around mixing genre with what you might
call him profit Ori style like the
Cassavetes or even Kazan to a certain
extent and blending the two and that was
it that was a failure at the box office
and in Hollywood and it sort of set me
off on a road feeling I never knew if
I'd had the passion again to do
something from myself we had to make a
movie again make a movie did everything
to ever make a movie again that came for
me because I realized that I just
couldn't go to work meaning go to work
like okay here's a script go there
Monday morning be there at 5:30 and tell
this person the person getting to that
actor had his own ideas or her own ideas
and you don't agree with them but you're
gonna have to go to I don't know if I
could do that I don't know if I the
energy to do it or really wanted to do
it and so a DeNiro during the period of
making New York New York and little
earlier actually when I was doing Alice
does liver anymore you give me the book
of raging bullet he wanted to make this
and by that point in time I wasn't it
seemed to be more generated from him and
as I said sports films I didn't get but
it's not a sports film I didn't realize
that until I gone through my own two or
three years of soul-searching and having
some difficult times and finally winding
up in the hospital and I found that
ultimately when I was in the hospital it
was kind of like a kind of a strange
miracle in a way I couldn't I couldn't
go any I couldn't reach any further down
I was in bottom and when he came to see
me and he just wanted really to make
that film he wanted me to get out of
that hospital bed too but he wanted me
to make me buddy want to make the film
come on you could do this you'd be so
greeted what are you doing with your
life look at you you know you know come
on please you could really do it I said
I said okay it suddenly hit me I think I
understood what it was and somehow
through him we had this extraordinary
collaboration mostly in a sense very
very collaborative and uh almost to the
point where we didn't necessarily have
to talk that we kind of felt similar
ways about my life and about people and
and the the process the artistic process
and just living trying to live being and
all these different emotions we felt we
kind of shared and so I thought that was
the film